I've been listening to this for the past, like, 15 minutes.
Welcome back to Astro Bot.
I don't know if you can see.
Game progress.
It says 100% behind there.
Yeah, I've gotten all the trophies.
Don't look at the left.
Yeah, I finished the game.
Don't look at the trophies.
Layer!
Oh no!
Spelling error in the group chat!
Spelling error in the stream chat!
Welcome back to Astro Bot!
I love this game.
And this game is so cute!
So embarrassing.
Yeah, I've been just chilling with this song.
I'm ready to start.
I have some stuff I need to do tonight.
So, oh my gosh, I just noticed that Planet is toxic.
Must have Twitter.
Okay, let's play the game!
Yeah!
I realized that I never showed you guys.
I like that music so much.
Like, it just kind of set your vibe to it before stream.
I mean, this one's great too, but...
Oh, I forgot how good this one is.
Astro Bot!
We have two monkeys!
Oh, oh, I'm trying to...
Astro Bot!
Since I have stuff I need to do today, let's just get into it.
Let's just start playing.
Let's just...
Let's just keep on rolling.
So let's... before we do that though, let's...
We're gonna go see what little guys we've got so far, you know?
Meow!
Hello, my people!
Hi, Snake.
So...
Oh!
Meow!
We have Metal Gear Solid!
We have them.
Like a spiral over here.
He doesn't do anything.
Ow!
What?
Like, I don't know why he's so obsessed with this.
This tree.
The boys.
We've got... Oh, I don't...
Oh, wait, this is, um...
Last of Us here.
We got them last time.
Meow!
Thank you!
Watching at the airport, so excited to see you.
A boat!
Even though there's no Waffle House to fight at.
Next time.
Next location.
Yeah.
Tonight, actually, I have sound checks.
For my concert tomorrow.
We got all the ape escapes.
We got Ratchet and Clank.
We got so many guys going on here.
I don't remember what that one is.
Um... Castlevania.
We got Persona.
We got Persona 4 last time.
Um...
We have all these regular guys.
The regs, you know.
These guys are normies.
Hello!
Welcome in!
Welcome in, everybody!
Welcome on!
The normies.
We got some Persona 3, too?
We did?
Oh, I forgot we got Katamari!
Stick!
Ow!
Oh, yeah!
We got Resident Evil!
Hold on.
I'm stuck.
There we go.
We got Resident Evil over here.
They're so cute!
So...
I don't know what we'll get today.
I do not know...
how far we'll get.
But I'm ready...
to go.
And...
Triggers!
Gosh, this game is just so cute!
God of War.
Oh, yeah!
Because we have...
What was it?
Over here?
Don't we have...
God of War here or something?
Or something?
Something?
Yeah!
Over here!
Right?
Here!
God of War!
Wait!
There's so many guys here!
Let's just get started!
Let's just dive right in, baby!
Oh!
What's that?
That's a glowing bird!
Yeah!
I got his butt!
Oh!
Nice!
I spoiled myself.
He should get the rest of the MGS characters.
I know there are some more, because I also got a little bit spoiled.
Though I am not sure where they are at.
Do not spoil for me, please, though.
I like to discover myself.
Look at that war...
Oh no!
Oh!
It's just a little worm in there!
I'll get you out!
Oh my God!
I get paid for rescuing him.
Oh, that's a snake.
That's not a worm.
Ouch!
They're up your butt!
Oh my God!
That's weird.
That's what that feeling is.
Oh!
What was this thing again?
Oh shoot!
I'm kind of a genius!
I think it's only those two things.
Okay.
There's two snakes here.
Nice.
I never know what guys I can use my fists on and what guys I need to jump and hit, you know?
Twin snakes!
Oh!
Oh my God!
Hey!
Watch out, man!
There's children there.
It's John, God of War!
Look!
He's...
Oh!
It's too heavy for me!
I'm just a bot!
No!
I'm just a...
Oh!
Never mind.
I'm kind of awesome.
Oh!
Why did I die?
Why does God of War get its own world?
Huh?
Oh my God!
I've become Kratos!
What?
Oh my God!
This is my baby now!
This is my child!
Come, come, boy!
Come, child!
Oh my God!
I can defeat everything with my fists!
Yeah!
Wait, what's...
Wait, huh?
What is it?
Oh, I can throw it!
Oh my god!
Uh, how do I get it back?
Wait, how do I get my...
Wait, how do I...
Um...
Wait, uh...
Wait, hold on!
Pick up.
Oh, okay.
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
Yeah!
Yo...
I'm very powerful right now.
Oh my god!
I don't think I'll ever stop using this now.
I'm like sniping them left and right.
Yeah!
It's so busted!
It's even auto-aims for me!
Oh my god, the music's so awesome!
It's so busted!
You guys!
The music is fun too!
I know!
Gosh... I really love that this is just kind of a...
Like a history lesson, you know?
Oh...
What's through here?
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Before we...
Before we gander...
I don't know why I keep saying that word lately.
I'm really sorry.
Um...
Before we view...
anything else, let's uh...
This looks...
Yeah.
I'll take that.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Uh, what is it?
Oh, sorry.
No, no.
How do I open this?
Gando.
Oh!
I did it!
Again.
Once again.
Uh, my genius...
is showing.
My genius is showing, everybody.
Minto tensai.
I know, I know.
Oh my gosh!
I can kill the bird!
Wait, hold on.
Alright, we need to properly... There we go.
What the?
Yeah!
I don't know what's special about these birds.
Why are we trying to kill them?
Tensai!
I have thunder goddess!
Big hair.
Bigger heart.
Hello!
Oh!
Who is that?
Boy.
Boy?
He said the thing!
Why do they...
What the?
What's that sound?
There's a little...
sound of electric...
Oh!
It's still alive!
You see his eye.
Oh!
There it is!
There we go!
It's still alive!
Okay.
Let's quote unquote save.
Here we go.
Alright, let's save and then let's go through here.
Boy.
I like ice scaling.
La la la!
La la la la!
Oh!
Oh my god!
The dogs!
Little pups!
Oh!
Uh...
Sorry!
Oh!
Game over!
Never be game over.
I don't think you're supposed to whip out your genius in public like that.
It's a free country!
It's...
What are these...
This one looks like a lady going to heaven.
And then...
This one...
I can't tell.
So the story is...
Dad gets Son...
A PlayStation.
And plays... and...
The Son is bad.
Okay.
You suck at the game.
So come here.
You're not good, Ironwood.
Oh...
Juh!
Turn!
Looks like a little face that's going like...
Paints a...
A prescient picture.
Oh!
He's playing Bot of War!
Sorry, dogs.
I just stole your master.
Maybe.
Oh my gosh!
Even like the painting has the...
The controller symbols.
Ow!
Bye!
Okay.
Onward.
I saw something behind there.
Okay.
So far so good.
And we got...
We've got...
Uh...
Oh gosh.
Two so far.
No misses.
Wolf bot.
Nice.
And I'm just gonna...
Wait.
Yep.
This thing is so...
Busted.
My god.
Oh, whoops.
I threw it too early!
Ah!
Is this how actual God of War is?
Kill that bird.
Oh my god.
I'm destroying everything.
I'm a monster!
100%.
There's another bird up there.
Ah!
There's another bird.
Oh.
No, no, no.
I see him.
Give me that bird.
If I go over there...
Hmm.
Throw axe.
Get axe.
I can do that.
In fact, I think I've proven my worth.
Oh!
How do I...
Grab.
There we go.
Oh!
This is...
New?
This is new.
We have not experienced this before.
Hold on.
I'm destroying your relics.
What's up there?
Hey!
Get away from my riches.
Alright.
God of War.
I'm already a god.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh!
I
don't know if we wanted to summon that.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Is this thing good?
Oh.
Hello.
We missed one.
Thunder god.
Oh shoot.
I forgot to read it.
I'm so sorry.
What if I just...
I was rewarded for my...
For my curiosity.
Careful.
We're careful.
There's a bird up there.
Is this guy safe?
I guess I'm okay.
Pleasant meeting you.
Oh!
He's actually quite cute.
I think.
This is such a nice photo op.
Cheese!
Oh.
Boy.
This song is killing me.
Oh shoot.
Wait.
How am I supposed to get back up?
Oh!
I climbed the thing.
I'm...
I'm a silly goose.
God of goose.
Here's a friend.
A serpent that goes around the world.
Wow.
My boy.
Alright.
Here we go.
What's over here?
Hello, turtle.
What do you got going on there?
I'm so sorry to disturb your...
This is kind of messed up.
He's just living his life.
He can't get back up.
Why would you do that?
Valkyrie clean.
The witch of the woods no more.
Whee!
Now she's just...
She's the witch of my controller.
Okay.
Oh?
Oh!
I don't think it would let me...
slip off, but...
Oh.
Uh oh.
Oh
shoot.
No!
My...
I thought my...
axe was like...
all powerful.
What's up with that?
I think I got...
I got...
a bamboozle.
Oh my goodness.
You can flip the turtle back over?
I can?
Oh, I see.
I see.
Come here.
Oh.
No, no, no, no.
Come here.
Oh, I get even rewarded for it.
Nice.
Saved.
Everybody, we're a good guy, okay?
We're a good guy, okay?
He is quite eepy.
Boy.
Even having never played God of War, this is quite fun still.
Okay.
Before we travel across that, though, I wanna go through here.
How do I...
Oh, like so?
A feather tree.
Oh!
Oh, this is where I go once I get all the birds!
I gotta kill them!
Oh, this is where their souls are!
Aha!
Oh!
It pays to explore, everybody!
That's a person!
I got a smartest man alive!
When it comes to wisdom, they're always ahead!
Ah!
It's in my mirror?
Is he sleepy?
Oh my goodness.
The feathers are kinda wild.
Alright, so we come back here later.
You guys, don't let me forget, okay?
Once we murder all these birds, okay?
Oh, there's even dogs here.
I'm a mirror.
Oh!
I like ice skating like this.
It's fun.
Oh!
Okay.
Except when.
Okay, nice.
Nice!
Take out the competition early.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh, uh...
We got it!
Ah!
Oh my gosh!
I...
I, uh...
I got a little...
Ah!
Ax got some range.
I know!
It's actually so awesome, right?
Okay.
We gotta do this again.
I got flattened, you guys.
How embarrassing.
Boy.
Oh my gosh!
I got...
I got too greedy.
I thought I could kill him.
I got too greedy!
I got too greedy.
It's my fault.
Yeah!
Literally, he's releasing my rage.
He's releasing my rage!
Masterful bait.
No!
Okay.
Now we can maybe... No, no, no, no.
I'm not gonna get greedy.
Now, here we go.
That's what I'm talking about.
Oh!
It was a little snowman of them.
I'm raging.
Oh!
There's this too.
Gosh.
This game continues to impress me.
Because it's so sweet looking, you know?
But it's also just so...
Oh my gosh.
It's also just so well-made.
Because it looks so good, you know?
But it's also just so cute.
They cooked with Astro Bot.
They did!
Dwarven Blacksmith!
The only thing bluer than their skin is their language?
What does that mean?
What does blue language mean?
They swear a lot.
Is that what it means to have a blue language?
Colorful language?
I see.
I think I get it.
I don't get it.
Like it's just so beautiful.
Oh!
Smush.
More.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
I missed a burp?
Look at the giant... look at the snake over there.
So funny.
I
think it's beneath you.
What?
Are you saying that the bird sucks?
Oh, I see him.
Nothing's beneath me.
I see him.
That's so mean to say.
Like he's just a bird.
I got it.
Can't wait for my happy come.
Thank you.
Gonna wear it to all the concerts, especially the death metal ones.
Yeah, you should.
Oh, wait.
I need... actually, I need that back.
Okay, here we go.
I knew there was something up with this platform.
Die, bird.
Thank you.
Oh!
Eyes of the Allfather.
Does that mean I got all the birds?
Okay, guys, we gotta backtrack a little.
I'm sorry.
Guys, we gotta...
Can I go from here?
I don't think I can make it.
Try it?
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh, wait.
How do I get back?
Do I actually have to go all the way back?
Why would it show me that area, you know?
If not...
Yeah, I do.
Okay.
Okay, upwards.
Oh!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh, okay.
Ooh, almost didn't make that.
Oh, it's not that far.
Okay, we're good.
We're all here.
It's not that far.
Now what?
Yes!
Uh...
Okay.
At least it satiated my curiosity.
It satiated...
Oh!
Oh yeah, what's my reward?
It's funny because this isn't really a backtracking type game, so it's like...
I was like, oh I have to go back?
Okay.
Have to throw your axe at the tree.
Oh!
Why did it turn the camera on me?
That's fine.
I think we're okay.
What is going on?
We're playing Astral!
But...
Look how cute this game is.
I feel like Kiara would really like this game.
Since she...
Since there's the...
Since you have her profile picture.
Her as your profile picture.
I feel like she'd really like this game.
I was watching her play the... what's it called?
Game a little bit.
The new Zelda game.
Oh, what the...
Hey, hey, hey!
What are you doing still alive here?
What are you doing here?
Hold
on.
Do I use him?
Oh my god!
I'm a genius!
Oh!
And we got everybody!
Dwarven artisan.
Strong metalwork.
Weak stomach.
Johnny?
Are you Johnny?
Collab when?
What, with Kimawa?
Whenever.
I would always love to collab with her.
How do we...
How do we get over to there?
Maybe I needed to keep one of the enemies.
Don't miss the jump.
Oh, really?
That's it?
Okay.
It was really that easy.
Yippee!
I like how they're just like, hey, by the way, you're going to have to, like, use your axe for things, and then you won't have access to it for the enemies.
Because we know that you're going to rely on it way too much.
And so we're just going to do...
Oh!
Oh, my gosh.
I'm tearing out his butt.
Oh!
Oh, my gosh.
He's got a big old tail and got a...
Oh!
Yeah, there we go.
I'm going to throw this at you.
He's dead!
Rescued ship pot!
Mentos.
No.
Mother ship's SSD allows space travel faster than the speed of loading.
Oh, that's it?
3, 2, 1.
That was so easy.
What's in the drive?
A folder that says homework.
It's night time.
Time for surgery.
Time for surgery everybody.
That's a lot of homework.
Busy, busy.
Why am I using a chainsaw?
Just let it thaw out.
A pack of
chainsaw.
I'll skin your eyes raw.
And my day keeps going this way.
I just might chain this.
SSD tonight.
But this is like hardware.
Are we sure we want to do this?
Play
the game.
I'm making music.
I don't know how the sound goes.
I'm part of the orchestra.
Okay.
Next.
Suddenly a rhythm game.
Oh my god.
There's a monkey in the corner that's just spinning around in circles.
It's so funny.
Okay.
I'm going to insert this in.
Nice and easy.
Hold on.
There we go.
Nice and easy.
And the square goes into the square hole.
You play a mean rectangle.
Thank you.
Okay.
Nice and easy.
It's kind of hard to figure out how to put it in.
Were those hard eyes?
Okay.
I'm going to be gentle this time.
Gentle.
Oh, this is gentle.
Gento.
Oh my god.
The eyes of
robots.
I said I was going to be gentle with them.
Okay.
Yippee.
Our SSD.
Don't make this weird.
It didn't make anything weird.
What are you talking about, Chucky?
It's literally in the game.
And...
See?
He likes it.
Solid performance.
Oh my god.
He's on a little memory card.
That's so cute.
SSD.
It was already weird.
This game is so cute.
I love how everything has a song.
SSD.
We have...
101 Dalmatians!
Okay.
Time to skin them all.
We're making a bot coat tonight.
Look how proud he is.
What's wrong?
They're like, Yeah!
Pull his ass!
They're pointing.
They're like...
This is what I watched my dad do to my dog after he ate the couch.
Okay.
I'll pull it out.
Oh.
No.
I need help.
I need help pulling this.
You shouldn't have eaten that.
Here we go!
Nice.
Yeah.
My dog had...
a couch in his butt.
He ate part of the couch.
Then my dad had to pull it out of his butt.
It reminded me of that moment, okay?
Where's Snake?
Where is he?
Wait.
How do I...
Snake!
Are you being a team player?
Wait.
Prince!
Oh my gosh.
I almost didn't make it.
Wait.
Whoa.
I'm just taking over this land.
There's creatures that live here.
I'm taking over.
Hey.
You guys stay here.
It's not safe.
Okay?
What's this guy?
Oh.
We need the whole crew!
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
What's happening?
What is this?
Wait.
We gotta kill these guys.
Come here.
I see Gray Fox.
Look at them.
Look at my army.
There's Snake.
Hold on guys.
I should secure the land first.
Probably.
Secure the land!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's do this.
Ahhh!
Is that stray cat?
Curious kitty solves puzzles.
Loves to dazzle.
Ahhh!
It's stray!
Oh my gosh.
We got a cat!
Best game ever!
Alright everybody.
Come up here.
Team players.
Oh.
Nevermind.
What are you guys doing?
Oh.
Oh I see.
But can we pet the cat?
I believe we should be able to pet the cat.
Oh.
You guys.
You guys steady.
Steady.
Steady everybody.
Oh wait.
I don't want this just yet.
Because it's gonna like restart the area.
Alright.
Umm.
Let's get everything else first.
They're like holding on for dear life.
Okay.
Come here guys.
We're...
We're in the pit.
Oh my god.
Snake is up on top of me.
There's more.
Very good everybody.
Rescued?
Shiba influencer.
When they bark humanity listens.
Wait.
What?
Why does he look like that?
What is he from?
We got a cat and a dog.
Humanity.
He's from humanity the game.
Wait.
I don't know that one.
It's an awesome puzzle game.
Oh.
I see.
Come here guys.
Oh wow.
Break them out.
Heave.
Ha.
Oh my gosh.
We're gonna kill them.
Oh my god.
Ah.
We rescued them.
Oh my god.
Why couldn't we just...
Okay.
Good job guys.
Why didn't you just drop down?
I like these guys.
They're cute.
Turtle.
Alright everybody.
Let's go upwards.
Don't fall down please.
I don't wanna lose anymore guys today.
Alright.
We have this guy over here.
Come here.
Nice.
I'll take that for sure.
We need 80 guys here.
That's a big dog.
Yeah.
I'm gonna...
Let me in.
Okay.
I'm here.
I can't move any...
Okay.
Push.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
I'm here.
There we go.
Evil.
Gosh.
There's so many guys down here.
What the hell is that?
Robotic sucker.
Gets under your skin.
Get in.
You're useless bot.
You're not gonna help me at all.
Did you know that 2024...
Wait.
Candlejack.
Still active.
What's that?
What is that?
Hey.
What are you doing down here?
Slacker?
Come on.
Join the rest of the team.
Snakes up there.
What are you doing there?
I think I got everything in this area.
Besides the...
I think that's everything in this area.
There's a pole thing.
There is?
Candlejack.
What is that?
Under the stairs?
This?
Oh!
This is just to get back.
This is just gonna launch us back.
It's not an actual thing.
What are you slackers doing?
Come on.
But good eye.
I didn't notice it.
I thought it would pop out automatically.
You did good.
Good job snake.
Look.
They're like...
They're directing.
Okay.
Steady.
See everybody?
Good job.
Okay.
Good job everyone.
You're not supposed to say candlejack otherwise...
Wait.
What am I doing?
Am I saying something?
Am I getting got?
Beep boop.
Oh.
I guess we're leaving.
He's gonna get you.
What?
It's a joke from Freakazoid.
Oh.
I never...
I know that show.
I just never really watch it.
Beep boop.
Snake.
Snake Galaxy.
Before that, let's dive on in and do some more gacha.
Snake.
Oh my god.
The god of war bots are huge.
I didn't see you for a second.
My stream started buffering.
Scary.
Alright guys.
Let's get something good.
There's a lot of stuff in here.
Oh.
It just keeps on...
The stream lagged after...
Wait.
What?
Heavy roller.
Striking fear into the heart of tenpins.
We got...
Is this a color?
Cyber Canary Dual Speeder.
Hello, sunshine.
Cute.
Origami bird.
Pray you never meet its maker.
Wait.
The origami killer?
Uh oh.
No way.
No.
Is he in this game for real?
No way.
Is the origami killer in here?
Wait.
I don't remember getting that guy.
Did we?
Oh.
Sorry.
Wait.
There's the origami.
Oh.
He's following me.
Jason?
No way.
It's the real origami killer.
Where's the cat?
Sean?
Oh.
Can I play?
Can I try again?
Thank you.
Yay!
First try.
I just saw it and went like...
Before I even...
Let's take off.
How are you liking Astro Bot?
I love Astro Bot!
Now...
There was...
There's a few bots we're missing here.
Should we try and get them?
Or...
Is it here?
No.
We're missing the portal here.
Oh.
The bots we're missing are...
These ones.
Ah.
The challenge levels.
The challenge...
Ah.
The challenge levels.
Oh.
What's this?
Wait.
Crumble rumble!
Let's try this one.
Maybe at the end of the stream I'll try.
Whoa.
Oh my gosh.
What am I supposed to...
Ouchie!
Okay.
Don't do that with them.
Is there a way to...
Kill these guys?
Okay.
They don't destroy the panel.
Uh...
Ow!
Oh!
What?
Can
I...
Can they throw fire at each other?
Cut the floor around them?
Oh...
It's like literally hanging on by a thread.
There we go!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Please.
Hey!
Where are you?
Pro golfer!
Loves birdies!
Especially eagles and albatrosses.
There's a golf!
Hot shots.
Ah.
Okay.
That was easy.
Yay!
We got a new guy!
Perfect.
There he...
goes!
Sucked into my world.
Um...
I know this one's a portal.
No!
Oh gosh!
Where was the portal?
Let's just go see.
These levels aren't very long.
So we can probably just...
Find it, you know?
Oh...
What if I get hit?
Oh!
Where was it?
Oh, the bird!
Oh!
We got that one.
I have to pay money though.
Ducky, thanks for the gift!
How do you do?
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh wait, I already paid for...
Oh, he's free!
Come here bird.
Free bird!
Hey, where's the secret?
Oh my gosh, that was close.
Where is it, bird?
Lead me!
Breakable floors and futuristic setting.
Really give that Crash Bash feeling.
We're back!
Thanks for the gift!
Is it here?
Oh, ouch!
Come here.
Bird?
Is it down here?
It's at the end of the level.
That's right!
I remember.
Oh, this one's kind of a long level.
This level's a little bit longer.
I'm going to have to...
We're going to have to...
speed run as much as I can.
We got this.
But we can get a bot coin.
Oh, I got it.
That was so easy.
Monkey!
Okay.
Floor it.
Okay, and this one is...
Oh, uh...
Oh, that's right.
We do a little...
something.
Oh, I got it.
Okay, there we go.
Thanks game!
And monkey smash!
Monkey grab!
Monkey grab, monkey grab, monkey grab, monkey grab.
Okay.
Destroy.
Monkey smash!
Okay.
Oh my gosh, this guy.
I forgot he moves.
Alright.
Monkey smash!
Smash.
Monkey grab!
Monkey smash!
Monkey!
Okay, monkey don't get hit.
Monkey don't get hit!
Monkey smash!
How many times do I have to keep monkey smashing?
I can't stop smashing!
I can't stop monkey smashing!
There we go.
Sheesh.
At least we get more coins this way, you know?
Okay, monkey...
grab!
Grab...
Monkey grab.
No...
Run, run, run, run.
Monkey hit, monkey hit.
Nice.
Mental gaming.
Okay.
I have to defeat...
the boss.
And then once I defeat the boss, it'll open up?
Is that how it was?
Mental gaming.
Monkey
grab.
Monkey grab.
Do I have to defeat him again?
I actually can't tell.
Is my chat frozen or is...
nobody talking?
I can't tell.
Am I still streaming?
Did my stream freeze?
Am I still...
Am I still live?
Oh, I'm live?
Oh!
Oh, I can see you guys!
Okay, hold on.
Sorry.
There we go.
Okay.
Yeah.
We're good?
Okay.
My chat froze.
So...
Do I have to defeat the boss again?
Or...
Am I good?
Beat the boss to unlock.
Where... How does he...
How do I get him to come out?
Hey!
What?
Here?
Approach the...
Oh!
There he is!
Woo!
I have to remember how to beat this guy.
That's right.
Wow!
And then we jump!
Monkey jump!
Grab!
Monkey grab!
Hold on with both hands for safety.
Oh my gosh.
That's right.
Don't get monkeyed.
Don't get monkey hit.
Monkey hit.
Fast!
Fast monkey!
And then on the back of him.
Ah!
Monkey!
Monkey jaw break!
Monkey decapitation!
Monkey win.
There it is!
Oh!
Thanks bird for your hard work.
Monkey murder!
Oh my god.
Riches beyond...
Riches beyond comprehension!
Oh!
What?
What do I...
How do I grab...
Hold on!
Hold on bird!
What do I get with this...
What do I...
What do I do?
Oh!
I have to throw it.
Monkey crash!
Oh my gosh!
My trophy!
Hold on bird!
We're going to disco land baby!
Here we go!
Oh!
What are those blue gems?
They're just decoration.
Robots don't care about actual money I think.
We are...
Oh!
Light bulb limbo.
Look!
We haven't gotten this one completely.
Oh!
We're missing a puzzle piece.
No!
This one we've gotten completely.
Secret!
Well let's try this one.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
This is perfect for Halloween!
Spooky!
Oh!
Where do I go from here?
Oh thank you.
Oh!
Okay.
I didn't mean to do that, but sure.
Whoa!
Frightening.
Oh!
Um...
I got you!
Destroy!
I think I can make that.
Oh!
Ah!
Um...
I don't like that.
I have to kill a ghost.
Family of yours?
Yeah.
My grandma's side.
Oh.
Okay.
Come here.
Hey!
Leave me alone.
Sleeper face.
I know.
Freaky.
The secret level.
Look!
I'm so scared!
Ah!
What are you so scared of?
I just realized the colors on my monitor versus the colors on OBS, the other monitor, are so different.
I wonder if they're that much different for you guys.
Wait!
Yay!
Shout!
I won on that.
Whoa!
This looks fun!
Look at all the dead robots.
Oh!
Oh no!
It's dead!
The Devil May Cry!
Son of Sparta!
Let's rock, baby!
We got Dante!
Yes.
Dante from the...
Oh!
From the Devil May Cry series.
Nice.
I hear something snoring.
Yoisha!
Is there something down there?
I want to like knock the little bones off.
Oh no.
You're gonna be a jerk to me while I'm trying to cross, aren't you?
Can I reach from here?
Run back.
Oh gosh.
We're smart.
We got this.
See?
We're smart.
We got
this.
What the ghost doing?
Eh, the ghost thing.
Those things.
Something's staring at me over there.
I
think the snoring's from in there!
Hey!
Get...
Get out of there!
Who is this?
This chap.
He's Noce...
Noscoth, the best reputation.
Okay?
From the original?
Legacy of Kain.
Yeah,
stay in there.
Okay, I don't think that was what was snoring.
I hear more.
Oh my goodness.
Maybe we...
Oh, don't do that.
Maybe we actually like...
aim and make it.
Maybe we should just...
Yes!
Oh my god.
Okay.
From here on...
There we go.
And heal.
There we go, nice.
Money.
Secret...
Look at the little spit-spitters!
I hear someone going...
Who is snoring over there?
Oh.
A fake coin!
It's bouncing around and everything like...
Oh my gosh.
It knows it's a fake coin.
At least it gives me real coins.
Who is snoring over there?
A mimic.
Real.
Mimic real.
Who are you?
Wait.
Huh?
Uh...
Hold on.
Hold on!
Oh.
Where...
Where's the entrance?
What?
Uh...
I think maybe I have to go in from the top?
Oh, it's that right there!
He's snoring!
Can I get over there?
Save my boy!
I'm trying.
Jump to him.
Afraid I might fall.
Oh!
Oh okay.
Oh no.
First,
okay there we go.
See guys, easy.
Nothing is too late.
It's too late.
When you don't succeed, try, try again.
Wake up!
Nice.
He's like, I'm alert!
I'm alert!
Why did you jump off?
So I could do that.
See?
Now for the puzzle piece!
It's everybody!
Resurrected Wraith.
You can't keep a good vamp down.
Oh my god, look!
It's you guys!
Oh, sorry.
Oh no, they're little mushrooms!
Oh my god, all these dead robots.
How'd they die?
They're little ghost mushrooms!
They're so cute!
I'm giving you love punches.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, I almost went.
That should be a gold.
That should be a gold flag, right?
Yeah!
It's only this one.
We missed a puzzle piece.
Secret.
I don't know what's taunting me.
Let's see.
We got here.
So...
I've done everything but enter this new galaxy.
We gotta go in here, guys.
Oh my god, that's me on my memory card.
Listen to me.
Oh shoot, we're going gambling, guys.
Let's go gambling!
And the challenge level, I know.
Oh no.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh gosh.
Where's the casino?
Ouch!
Oh, okay.
My bad.
Excuse me.
There it is, I see it.
I see the casino.
Slowmo Casino.
This level's fun?
Okay, I'm so excited.
Oh!
Are you okay?
You almost died!
Oh my god!
The truck is like, how do I get out of here?
What is this?
Oh, it said... oh my gosh, we're in VR.
It said slow-mo, do we... so...
Run!
Oh my god.
These are my dice.
This is so... oh my god, look at all of them go!
Oh my god!
No wonder it's so easy to have an accident here!
Oh my gosh!
What are the little...
ferrets?
Can I get on top?
Oh nice, I can.
I can't.
Anything else?
Oh, there's more stuff over here.
Okay...
Wait, what if I...
How do I use the slow-mo again?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, oh gosh.
Oh, oh gosh!
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
I think I gotta...
Have to use this gimmick a lot, yeah.
Okay.
Up, up, wait, up-see!
Up-see!
Oh god, bot wants up-ees, please!
Bot!
Bot wants up-ees, please!
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Oh, oh my god, I suck at this.
My depth perception.
Can I make this?
Oh, I can!
Oh, I did it!
Oh wait, was there anything up there?
Okay, there's something on that side.
I feel like there's gotta be something here.
I don't think I see anything up there.
Oh, guess I do!
Oh, I do see things up there!
Um, okay, oh.
I gotta let it recharge, I think.
Oh, oh, oh gosh.
Uh...
Uhhh...
Is that how I do it?
I like...
Use the dolphins as...
Oh, um... I think I did too early.
Oh, maybe not?
Ah, no!
No!
This one's tricky.
Oh, so close.
Okay.
Nice!
We got him, baby!
We got him, baby.
Come in, normal guy.
Little normie.
Little normal man.
Normbo.
He's just a normal guy.
Alright, nice.
We shmovin'?
Oh, oops.
Just gotta...
Into the casino!
Oh, thank you.
I'm a distinguished guest.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Woah!
I missed one?
What do you mean I missed one?
I missed a guy already?
Am I getting one guide?
I am?
Okay.
Stop one-guying me!
Gosh.
Ahhhh!
Oh my god.
Ready...
Stop!
Aw.
Ready...
Steady...
Stop!
Come on.
Are all of these bad options?
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
I have a slow-mo.
Haha, I can cheat.
Oh, dang it!
I can cheat.
Where do I have to reach up and grab him?
Three, two, one, go!
Ah!
I got him!
Thank you!
Ah, dang it!
Hey, monkey!
This is my game!
Is there anything here?
Slow...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oops.
I don't know how to do slots, you guys.
Ha!
Oh.
One, two...
Oh!
Ah!
I was...
Um...
Ha!
Oh, gosh!
Ah!
Hey!
Ha!
Duh!
Oh, where's my little man?
You own a slot machine.
It's different!
I don't own a...
Oh, I do own a slot machine.
You're right.
Um...
Sorry.
I was going to say it's not a pachinko machine because everyone calls it a pachinko machine.
You're right.
It's a slot machine.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Well, that's it.
Let's go, game.
Ah!
Sorry.
I
feel like I'm cheating, though.
I want to play...
I want to play with my real luck, okay?
I'm going to close my eyes.
I'm going to close my eyes and I'm going to hit it.
Oh.
Oh, I was so close.
I want to do real gambling, you guys.
Gamble!
No!
My own
intuition.
I won't get it from... from cheating.
Let's go gambling!
Yeah!
Dang it!
Oh...
Financial...
Ah!
AHHHHHHHHH!
RESPONSIBILITIES!
BE DAMNED!
AHHHHHHHHH!
3, 2, 1...
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I give up.
That
was basically my own ability.
Yeah,
monkeys, you don't get the satisfaction.
In the end, it was a skill issue.
Never has been, never has been, never has been.
There are so many animals in this place.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Stop, stop.
Oh, nice.
Can I make it over there?
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Yippee!
Now can I make it on top of these?
Grab all that cash money, baby.
What is that guy zooming around there for?
What is this?
What are the lyrics?
Something the slot machine.
Sorry, I thought I would spin around with it.
I thought I would also go spinning.
Wait a second, do I have to do that all over again?
99% of gamblers give up before cheating.
Wait, do I have to do this all over again?
No, you guys, I got cheated.
Your coins get saved, but they're still up there.
Huh?
I got cheated.
I didn't have enough juice.
Maybe I have to lose.
Huh.
That's so weird that it doesn't give it to you again.
Oh.
And...
See, I would have hit it then anyway.
Hm.
He's lost his will to live because he's lost so many times.
Your coins don't get saved unless you checkpoint.
Oh, see, that's what I'm saying.
So I did lose those coins because...
Wait, that's so sad.
I lost my coins.
Because it wouldn't give me the little thing again.
What?
No.
That's so not fair.
I'm not being greedy.
I'm wanting to do more gacha.
Oh, I can't...
Oh, wait.
There we go.
More gacha.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's this thing again.
Wait, what am I supposed to do with you?
Oh, I need you over here.
Uh...
I need you over here.
Excuse me.
Thank you.
Holy cow.
Oh my god, these go so fast.
Is there anything that I missed?
Let's take a little look around.
A puzzle piece.
Oh, oopsie.
I got too excited.
Oops.
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
Puzzle piece.
Nice.
Hey!
It pays to look.
Oh my gosh.
If you fall though, you die.
If you fall, you're dead.
You're donezo.
Ah!
Just like that.
Oh, uh...
Oops.
Okay.
Oh.
What is going on here?
What the hell?
We're fine.
We made it.
We're good.
Parkour.
Fastest parkour in the West.
Got it.
Oh my God.
Die!
We made it.
You guys.
What is your card?
Oh wait.
No.
Don't tell me what your card is.
Oh.
Sorry.
Don't tell me what your card is.
Is this your card?
A queen of hearts!
Alright then.
So, you crash on those 16 cards.
I'm the very second Queen of Hearts!
Magic, baby.
What is that goober doing over there?
What are you doing?
Do you make like a... Oh my god.
Oops, sorry.
Shoot.
Almost gaming.
Yeah, I almost gamed.
Oh come on!
Wait, there's a puzzle piece down there!
Oh, okay.
Actually that was good, that was good.
Okay, now we know to get back into the middle once we're done.
Okay.
Nice.
We're gaming, we're gaming, we're gaming.
We're gaming, we're gaming, we're gaming!
Puzzle piece behind the chameleon.
He didn't even have to tell me.
Alright, guys.
Is your heart... card?
I didn't mean to say heart.
I was saying...
Is your card the Queen of Hearts?
Wait.
Wait,
this one, this one.
This is the one I was trying to hit.
What?
Don't look at that one.
Wait.
Is your card the Queen of Hearts?
Oh, I see coins over there.
Okay, don't let me forget the coins over there, guys.
Oh.
I should have landed on the pieces, huh?
Uh -huh.
Oh, I'm gonna have to get this coin... or this piece again.
Oh wait, no, I don't have to get it, but I have to get the coin again.
You know what?
Screw the coin.
Sorry, guys.
I'm just gonna do what I did before.
Take it this time!
Look behind the respawn area here.
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
How do I get to him?
Uh...
One second!
I'll figure it out!
Oh!
Oh, it's here!
This is it.
Thank you!
Oh, it's Sly!
Ringtail thief!
A master of taking things on!
I'm the Sly!
Sly Cooper!
Yeah!
Oh, thank you, guys.
Even though I hate this part.
Oh, because I'm not very good at it.
Oh, gosh!
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Oh, don't get underneath the thing.
That will help.
Come on!
There we go.
Nice.
And...
Now!
Destroy!
Get more coins.
Thank you!
What?
I got his butt!
Oh, shoot!
Ow!
Shoot!
Oh, shoot!
I have to...
Ow!
I got him.
I got it.
We're fine.
First try!
See?
Confetti!
Oh, I didn't notice the chameleon.
Oh, don't forget the coins!
Thanks!
Thank you.
Oh, my gosh!
Coins!
Okay, I'll get you second.
All right.
Normie rescued!
Oh, my gosh!
Okay.
We gotta avoid this guy.
While also...
Oh, my gosh!
He shoots chameleons!
While also being on the dice.
Okay.
This is a little dicey.
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, you guys!
You guys!
Can we still get him?
Or...
Okay.
Good.
Yeah.
We still got it.
Okay.
Good.
Bad roll.
For real.
Oh,
my gosh!
He just keeps going.
Okay.
We're gonna have to wait for the dice to be close to each other and him...
Go for it.
Here we go.
Nice.
I got him.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
I got him.
Where's the... where's the save point?
Where are we going?
What the heck is that?
What is going on here?
Do I fall in there?
This seems nervous.
It's a pool?
Oh!
Secret!
What?
Dice tumbler!
They're on a roll!
That was it?
There's coins and stuff in there.
There's...
I see more...
I see more money.
So, it doesn't matter if I...
Oh!
No!
Back inside.
Okay.
Secret!
Oh!
I just have to hit them with my fist.
Okay.
This is strange.
Nobody can play dice game.
It's like it's not...
It doesn't play the secret music anymore.
All right.
I think we got everything over here.
Very good.
Okay.
Back we go.
And over to here.
Here?
Oh!
Good.
Okay.
There's our...
First try?
There's our save point.
Oh!
This guy sucks!
Come on!
You suck!
Oh!
That's too slow.
Nice!
Oh gosh!
And...
Oh!
Right on it.
See if there's something there?
I do see...
Oh!
I see money.
And...
Oh!
Come on!
We got the money!
Oh!
Gosh!
There's so many tiny things in this game you got to pay attention to.
Okay.
All right.
This guy kind of sucks.
I don't...
I really don't want to do that again.
But I think I might have to.
I think I'll probably mess it up again, you guys.
I'm just going to say it.
What's happening?
Oh!
You're a genius.
That's not just something you can say lightly, okay?
Not everyone can just say, I'm a genius.
You know?
Like...
Oh!
Kill him!
Fine!
I'm a genius too.
I did it first try.
Ha ha ha ha!
You guys!
Is!
Your card!
This!
Eight of diamonds!
Ten of spades.
No, it wasn't!
Persona!
Oh, shoot.
Fly!
Rescue!
We got all of them!
Phantom Thief!
You'll never see him coming!!!
Hahaha!
You're so cute!
Joker...
You'll never see him coming!
Boing!
So...
Now it's...
Oh, no.
It's still sending two of them.
We're still sending two of them.
Just a little...
Maybe here?
Have you played any of the Persona games?
I played a tiny bit of P4.
But I...
actually never played so much.
For some reason I couldn't really like get into them.
I'm not really good with turn-based combat.
Too much thank you.
Please.
Please!
Wait,
how am I supposed to do this?
Big money!
You gave me platforms, but could you just move them a little bit closer?
Okay, that's fine.
This is Vegas, baby.
They're trying to kill everybody who wins.
They're like, winner!
Not on our watch.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Can you not freak out right now, please?
I'm scared.
Okay.
Oh!
I made it.
Uh, I guess I don't need that platform.
The house always wins.
Exactly.
They're like, yes, you won.
I'm having to play American Warrior, American Ninja Warrior over here.
To get my riches.
Oh my God.
And then they put me up against the Mafia.
Hopefully there was nothing on that.
I'm worried I missed something, but...
Oh, what the?
Nice.
I
don't know what I'm supposed to press the button for.
But I'm just going to keep doing this.
To make sure... How do I do the map again?
We're missing a puzzle piece.
Oh no, you guys.
We're missing a puzzle piece!
No!
Puzzle piece doko.
Table games and slot machines.
Oh my God.
No!
We missed a puzzle piece.
That platform down there.
The one that I missed on accident.
I don't think so though.
Where could it have been?
It's probably hidden somewhere.
Wait a second.
Oh!
I see it!
You see those coins down there?
I think that's probably where it is.
Oh gosh.
No way.
If I just jump, I could probably make it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh God.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Wait.
Okay.
No, I keep missing.
Ah!
I keep missing.
I somehow made it.
I don't think I got all the coins.
Maybe I did.
Who knows?
Minto Gaming!
I'm a platformer gamer now!
Oh no.
I definitely did not get all the coins.
Table games and slot machines and blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Now I am.
Completionist.
Oh!
Ah!
Yeah!
There we go.
Minto Gaming.
Guys, now we have to get back there.
Now we have to get all the way back to the top!
If you die, does it work?
But all my money!
Money!
20 stairs?
Are you sure?
I can't remember where the last checkpoint was, though.
I'll be honest.
I can't remember if it was up there or not.
I can't remember.
It's fine.
Oh.
Let's redo that.
Reach up to the top.
Reshuffle?
And...
It's okay.
It wasn't that far of a jump.
It wasn't that far.
We're fine.
We're fine, probably.
Time to find out where we...
See?
You guys, I would have to do this anyway.
I farm coins by restarting levels without reaching checkpoints, so I think they don't disappear.
Oh, really?
Oh, okay.
Well, I'd have to redo this part anyway, so...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I got the same.
Damn.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Last bit.
Nice.
Gaming.
Okay.
Oh.
Joker, what are you doing?
Huh?
Gold flag?
I think?
Probably?
Yeah.
Do we go monkey?
Or do we go iron giant?
Free Big Brother.
Bathhouse, bathhouse, bathhouse.
I've always wanted a brother.
There's a lot.
And actually, there's the same in both.
You know what?
Let's just go to brother first.
I've always wanted a brother.
Bathhouse because of yesterday's stream.
Oh.
Oh my god.
He really looks like the iron giant though, doesn't he?
Thank you.
Oh my god.
He's covered in parasites.
This is horrible.
Why is the music like... it's too chill for what's going on here.
Hey.
Leave him alone.
Yeah.
Brother.
Okay.
Oh my god.
We have a little umbrella.
It's too cute.
Hey, buddy.
They chained him up.
They chained up our brother.
The little umbrella is too cute.
Oh.
Wow.
Okay.
You know what?
I say like that's so obvious but that's also... it seems very easy to miss at the same time.
If I...
Can I swim in this level?
I can.
Oh.
I'm very fast.
Where are you taking me?
Bird.
Where are you taking me, bird?
What are you...
What are you doing?
What am I...
What am I doing?
Oh.
Where am I?
I think this is a different way to get over here.
Oh my god.
Oh.
That scared me.
Okay.
There's a lot we got to handle around here, guys.
Yeah.
Get up.
Oh my god.
He's free.
Yeah.
There's stuff everywhere.
So we're going to have to really walk around and explore.
Oh.
We're going to have to explore everything.
So if I miss something, feel free to yell at me, but give me a chance to look around and get it all first for myself.
Okay?
No!
That's not which way I wanted to go.
Oh well.
Let's just go over here too since we need to.
Yeah.
Huh.
Why?
Okay.
You have both arms now.
Just lift.
You are humongous.
You're huge.
Just lift.
All righty.
What's this one?
He's like, no, not yet.
I can't do it.
Okay.
No puzzle pieces.
Oh my god.
There's a little swimming guy.
So cute.
Oh my god.
This is a good vantage point.
He's eepy.
Aw, eepy big bro.
Onii-chan, okite.
Okite, onii-chan.
Okite, okite, okite, okite, okite.
Let's go back to the bird.
Oh wait.
Mada nemoi.
Not this way.
Over.
Over there.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
We're gaming, guys.
What the hell are those?
What are you...
I've never experienced those guys.
Oh no.
Wait.
How much progress did I lose?
Oh no.
I made it.
Well...
Aww, man.
I have to do these guys again.
Huh.
They don't make this easy.
Ay.
Do I bait him?
Oh, then I pull him!
Ah-ha-ha, I see.
I see.
Then I pull him.
Yeah!
There we go!
Got him.
Got him, got him, got him.
You're welcome!
Oh, Beast Tamer!
I didn't even realize this was a guy.
Will grow up to have an incredible story to tell.
Who is this?
Last Guardian?
She's like, you got rejected by your crush today?
Sorry, I'm not laughing.
Okay.
I'm not laughing.
That's so sad, I'm sorry.
Why are you...
I'm just laughing because you said it in my chat.
Sorry.
No, I'm just laughing because you said it here.
It's just kind of random, you know?
That's all.
It's not funny.
It's just kind of random, that's all.
That's all.
It's not funny.
I promise.
It's just random.
That's all.
I'm trying to see if there's anything else that I should fly over to.
Oh, interesting.
There is...
A jumping platform down there.
So we shall check out...
Why?
Later.
After we beat this up.
We freed him!
Brother.
Big brother.
Oh my god, and it's sunny now!
Happy day!
Oh.
I guess it's just if you fall off.
Okay, never mind.
What's that?
Okay, maybe that's where a portal is?
Happy day!
Big coin.
I know, but there's still more to explore.
Just a little bit.
Because...
Look how much we're missing!
There's another... See that... that sparkly area up there?
We gotta get to there.
And...
Oh,
and in here.
Okay, hold on.
Do you think...
Let's... let's drop down first.
It's okay!
You got this!
Oh!
Nice!
You're getting slide, Cooper.
Remind me.
If you ever open a safe... a safe away...
Wait.
If you ever open a safe away.
To send your stuff.
Safe?
Oh.
I have slide games on the PS2.
I would let you borrow them for stream.
Safe?
Oh!
A P.O.
bar!
I was like, huh?
Thank you!
Sorry.
I'm... I'm... I'm... Sorry.
I'm a little dumb.
I was like, safe away.
Safe... away.
I was like, I thought you meant... like if I ever opened a safe...
Like I was... like a spy.
You know?
If you ever... like if you ever found... a way to open a safe...
How do I get up there?
I thought maybe jumping... climbing up and then falling down might be our best way.
Do I actually have to parkour here?
Oh, dang it.
Oopsie.
Break more of the platform?
I see!
Thank you guys.
Oh.
Secret.
Oh, I see.
Wait.
Slumbering girl.
It takes a whole lot of effort to wake her up.
Nice.
Okay, good.
We haven't missed one yet.
What's this?
A bird.
Oh.
Okay.
No, no, no.
There has to be more in there.
There has to be more secret.
There has to be more.
But we can't fall.
There has to be other platform.
Right?
Or maybe not.
Wait.
I don't see anything.
You guys are saying no?
Watch this.
Goal!
Okay.
I believe you guys.
I believe you.
Cool.
But we're still...
Oh, I see another...
I see the other puzzle piece.
But we are still missing a warp and four guys.
Uh...
A warp and four guys.
Okay.
We got all the puzzle pieces though.
The level's not over.
Yeah, that's true.
That's very true.
Oh, there is this area.
Right here.
I was like, maybe this is the warp.
Oh!
We got a guy?
Very good!
Never mind, that's not our warp though.
Okay, let's... I guess... do here?
And see if this is...
If it continues.
Oh!
Oh my god, big brother!
Big brother!
Brother, use your hand!
Lift me out of the water!
Your hand!
Your fingers are really big!
Okay.
Always wind it up, brother.
Oh my brother!
You have little parasites on you.
Oh!
Who's this?
Wandering trespasser.
Has a colossal task ahead of him.
Nice.
Main character of Shadow of the Colossus.
Oh my goodness!
I've never played Shadow of the Colossus.
Oh, brother.
Oh brother, you're kind of scaring me.
What big eyes you have!
Why is there still... wait, why is there a checkpoint?
Brother, how much more of this level do we have, brother?
Oh brother, there's a lot going on down there.
Brother!
Brother, if I drop, will you catch me?
Brother.
Brother, catch me!
Okay, brother.
Not cool, brother.
Not cool.
He's taking me up.
Oh!
The bird is more helpful than you, brother!
The bird is more helpful than you!
What is this?
This thing
that we're climbing, anyway.
I don't really understand it.
I hear someone.
I hear you!
Okay, just one guy left.
Sally's Seashows.
And we are indeed by the seashore.
What are you doing, brother?
Oh.
I hear something?
I hear a guy.
He's like in my left ear.
Where are you?
Do you guys see him?
Am I crazy?
Okay, hold on.
Let's get on it, brother.
Brother, that can't be the end of the episode, please.
We have more...
Okay, you can lend more than a finger.
Come on.
Brother, don't be like that!
Brother, you're being stingy!
Brother, what if I fall?
I will die!
Brother!
Oh, there he is!
We still... didn't get the warp.
We're still missing the warp.
Oh my god!
It's Venus!
The warp is back below?
Okay.
Before I take that...
We're back below?
How below are we talking?
Brother...
Bestow your wisdom upon me.
All the way below?
Back in the main area.
Shoot!
Okay, bye brother!
Oh my god, that actually made my tummy drop.
But if I... get the warp...
The thing about warps that's so annoying is you have to redo the level, you know?
But since I'm here, might as well do it.
Alright, warp, warp, warp, warp.
Warp, warp, warp, warp.
If I were a warp...
Where would I be?
In the shell?
No.
If I were a warp, I would be up here.
If I were a warp, I...
If I were a warp...
Hold on, I'm looking around.
I'm looking around.
It's not over there.
I noticed it earlier.
I go check it out.
Oh no!
Oh...
Okay, let's go beat the level.
Okay, but to be fair...
What's wrong, brother?
He's like, I lost my... I lost my brother!
Brother, I'm here!
Brother, I'm not dead!
I'm not lost in the ocean!
Brother, lend me your hand!
Brother...
Okay, nevermind.
Oh, he respawns?
Oh, okay.
I can't decide what I want to do.
Beat the level or do the warp.
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
So he...
Electrocute this area!
I found it!
I
found it!
Thanks guys for your help.
What do we have here?
Another Spook... Ghouls and Birds!
You guys, I'm getting all the best levels today!
Secret...
How many Metal Gear characters?
Just...
Just a Metal Gear Solid one.
I know there's more.
Don't tell me who.
I just know there's more.
And don't tell me where.
Ew!
Oh my god, they're little zombies.
They're little mummies!
So cute!
Oh!
He's looking at me like...
Kuro-kuro-kuro-kuro!
Oh, I got you!
John Metal Gear.
Nasty!
Oh my gosh, it's so spooky!
Oh gosh, you guys, I love horror.
I love horror.
Oh my goodness.
Nice.
Oh, it's this thing again.
Oh!
He's like...
Calculus 2 has been kicking my butt ever now!
Any words of encouragement from Kamiyoshi?
Oh, I see.
Numbers?
Numbers are not even real.
Numbers...
were created by humanity.
You can forget about them.
You got this.
Freak.
Go list the bots.
Yes.
I am numbers.
Created by humans.
Who wish to pay me a tribute.
Oh!
Tribute?
You steal men's souls and make them your slaves.
Uh-oh.
Wait, you guys, if I...
Guys, if I do this...
How am I gonna get back?
Oh!
Guys, I think I made a grave mistake.
Thank you!
Fragile knight.
Relieved that they remembered to put on underwear.
What does that mean?
Oh!
Never mind!
The game loves us!
The game is so kind!
The game is kind.
Loves us!
I don't know how much I super chatted you.
I forgot.
That is...
Okay, wait.
That might be an important...
Oh!
I forgot.
Bye-bye!
You bastard ghost, you!
Bastard ghost, bastard ghost!
Screw you, screw you ghost!
Wait, there's something down there.
Wait, so I can fall into the toxic waste?
Or...
So it's fine to...
Okay, hurry, hurry, come on!
Come on!
Oh my god, please.
Triumph checkpoint.
I guess that's true.
Because otherwise...
Like, why does it have the thing down there?
But at the same time, I don't want to do that fight again.
Oh, it's an invisible platform, I think.
Why is the food so huge?
Yeah!
Now
I can actually go do it.
Here, let's see.
Let's see what happens if we fall.
Oh my god, I need this carpet!
This rug is so cute!
I think I need it.
Oh, that's fun.
Where does that come from?
Wait a second!
Wait a second, how do I get that?
Wait.
Is this his room or something?
Wait a second.
That was Sir Arthur from Ghosts and Goblins.
When he gets hit, he loses his armor and runs around in his underwear.
Why is his hand like that?
Oh my gosh.
I'm living on the edge, for real.
Stop spying.
Oh, maybe he needs... he wants me to spy.
Have you seen the door in that thing?
Oh, I just completely wasted it, but that's okay.
Oh, there's creepy crawlies in the window.
Oh, there's a hand!
Wait, I think we need a running start.
Please, grab it!
Oh, no!
My depth perception!
No!
Oh, I got it, finally!
Oh my goodness.
There's a puzzle piece there.
Cute!
Baby Cortex and the Gifted!
Depth perception, you guys!
Depth perception!
He's like, hey!
Hey, can I have my head back?
Spooky, scary skeletons and shivers.
Even the bird.
Shivers up your spine.
Make it sure I...
Let's grab Vanilla.
This game is so adorable.
Isn't it alright?
Oh gosh, leap of faith.
Please!
I got it!
Depth perception.
Oh, depth perception.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, leap of faith!
Ah,
there we go.
Okay.
We got...
Eternal Knight?
Make no bones about it, there...
Is this medieval?
Ah!
Open up!
Sir Darn!
I remember him!
Another sleepy guy.
I must get puzzle piece.
Puzzle piece is so important.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Oh, I'm scared.
Okay.
Get out of my... Oh, that's a mimic.
And I am free run.
I think we have to blow it, you guys.
Any puzzle pieces down here?
Secret people?
Chill,
chill, chill, chill.
Stop it!
Stop!
Can I just kill you?
No?
Oh,
I got it.
I don't know how I got it, but I got it somehow.
We're still missing a puzzle piece and a person.
The game is bullying me for my size.
It's not very kind.
See, that looks like an area.
Oh, maybe not.
Okay, let's just continue onward for now.
See what else there is.
Oh!
Ecto gang!
What the heck?
What the hell is this Luigi?
Luigi's Mansion.
What do I do?
Oh, R2.
Okay.
Got him.
Oh, I got juked.
Oh my gosh, it's just like a... Oh no.
It's just like a whack-a-mole.
Oh my god.
I got him.
Whack-a-mole.
Whack-a-mole real.
Uh-oh.
I'm missing people though.
Shut up!
I
got it!
Impractical butcher heavies the head that wears the pyramid.
I don't know yet if I'm going to play the new Silent Hill.
Okay, that looks like we're a puzzle piece.
Wait.
So does that.
I think I can get down there.
I think I can go in there.
There's no warp.
Oh, we're in the warp area.
No, it's not down there.
It was by the rope.
Which rope?
I missed it.
Shoot.
Goodnight.
Can I go back?
Ow!
Try dying?
Yeah, let's try.
Nah, the game said, you beat the level.
The pain.
That's so rude.
There's no way I can go back at all.
Doesn't look like it.
Oh man.
Yeah, at least I know where it is.
So true.
Oh my god, look at those spinny ghosts.
They're so cute.
Oh, Pyramid Head.
Dang it.
I'm not going to go back right now though to get it.
I will go back another time.
Yeah, I'm not sure yet if I'm going to play the new...
I've heard though that it's getting good reviews.
So I would like to be optimistic.
I don't know though.
They say it's good.
Wow!
Look how many we got!
We have so many bombs!
And we unlocked a new thing!
Time for a change!
The changing room is open!
The only thing left is to find the perfect outfit.
What is this?
It's gonna be that place right there, right?
Hey, hey, hey!
What are you doing?
We gotta do gacha.
Time for gacha.
Gimme!
Calling card!
We got the joker's calling card!
Cute!
We have...
We got sla... oh there's the safe!
No safe is safe!
Let's go!
This one's heavy.
Gravity shifter outfit!
Fall with style.
Wait, this looks so familiar.
What is this from?
Cobalt Dusk Deep Blue Sea?
Gravity Rush!
Treasured Memento.
Aww...
Souvenir from an unforgettable friend.
What's this one?
Acer Cleaver.
Asgard as it gets!
Gimme more outfits!
Oh my god, I thought that was the Buster Sword for a second.
Doesn't even look like it, but...
More outfits!
Oh, I kinda like the pink one though.
Oh, we got Kratos' campfire.
Magical smithing!
Come on, more outfits!
Anti-demon set!
Oh gosh, I need to play Devil May Cry soon.
I'll get around to it.
Sooner rather than later.
Don't worry.
Thirsty Cutlass.
Friendly drone!
Oh, cute!
It's for strife!
And last one...
Legendary Hammer.
So much god of...
Oh, there's all the outfits now!
Meow!
Meow...
Oh my gosh.
They have their own little area.
So lonely!
Let's go in here.
We did get an outfit.
It's kind of exciting.
Oh, I have two outfits, apparently.
I have two outfits, apparently.
Oh...
So cute!
Wait, but this one is so cute.
Happy Myoshi is streaming my favorite game from this year on my birthday.
Nora!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Nora.
Happy birthday!
We'll stick with this one.
Oh my gosh, I'm so cute!
Wait, are there any Alphas from Metal Gear?
Don't tell me.
Don't tell me if there are.
And if there's not, I'll just be really sad and cry.
I want the pink one.
Everybody, look at all of them.
So cute.
Come back!
Everybody, all these little robots are so moe.
They're so stupid.
I love it.
They're all so moe and dumb.
Stupid.
One more try, please.
There we go.
Wait, where's my money?
Where's my money?
What's this?
Wait, what the heck is this?
Why is this so cute?
Happy to see you stream on my birthday.
Oh my gosh, my fianc.
I've been playing MGS because of you and we just got a kitten named Ryden.
Strawberry, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
Strawberry tarot.
Happy birthday to you.
It's so cute.
I keep forgetting.
Well, I don't forget that this is a game for their 30th.
But I'm also just like, oh yeah, this is for PlayStation 30th.
I could farm some coins a little bit, but I'd rather just go play some more levels.
Let's go to some more worlds.
I wonder if there are Metal Gear outfits.
It's only Quiet's outfit!
Yo!
Toro's videos, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
The bathtub?
What's the bathtub?
Oh, no, no, no.
It's a snake.
And let's go.
Nice, nice, nice!
Let's go to monkey.
Monkey town!
Bathhouse battle?
Okay.
I played this yesterday.
Hey!
Leave that little monkey alone!
The monkey's in my bathhouse.
Monkey's in my bathhouse.
Is there something over here?
I hear something, like, moving, like...
Oh, here.
That is really pretty.
It sounds like something's taking pictures.
Oh, whatever.
Oh, I see, I see money up there.
Where there's money, I follow.
Yep!
I hear you!
Hold on!
I must go to the money first!
I'll get you after!
Be patient!
God.
Be patient.
I must go where the money follows.
There we go.
Our first rescue.
Rubber ducky.
Hey, that's my rubber ducky.
Can you throw it?
Oh my god, there goes the monkey!
Nice.
Whoa.
Oh.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hands off!
Oh, there's a guy in here.
What... are we?
My favorite power-up.
What?
Oh!
I'm a sponge!
Wait, am I...
What am I doing?
I'm, like, watering it, I think.
I'm making it all wet.
I'm moistening the flowers.
What?
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
I got it!
I understand now.
R2 to...
Oh, so it sprays.
Is it, like, an attack too, even?
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
Oh, I thought it was just I run around and I...
And I... help them out, but no.
Oh my god!
This is so cute!
How does this game continue to, like, get me so much?
I'm just like, what?
Everything they do, I'm just like, oh my god!
Every concept feels so...
So good!
These sponges are so stinking cute.
I know!
They really ate with this game.
Like, damn.
Oh, I'm...
Yeah!
I am sponge destroyer!
Oh, I got two.
Oh, I got him.
Is there anything here?
I should be looking more off the side of the cliffs.
I feel like Godzilla is...
Like, oh, it's crazy.
Yeah!
You can't hurt me!
I'm crazy!
Oh, no.
Not sludge.
Not on my watch.
Ew!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
He was drowning!
Hold on.
I'll save you.
She's freaky.
Oh my god.
This poor guy.
Are you okay?
This is the best bathhouse.
Oh, sorry.
I can't control my size, everybody.
I can't control my size.
I can't...
I'm crazy.
Looks like there'd be something over there, but I can't tell.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oops.
I didn't even notice him.
Not on my... watch?
Yeah!
Ducky!
Destroy everything!
Destroy!
Oh my god.
Wait.
Actually...
Oh.
Is this a secret?
Is this one?
So let's try going this way.
But this one has the...
Oh.
No!
Yeah.
Death.
Oh.
I have to go small.
Just kidding.
Is this the way I'm supposed to be at?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
They're destroying everything!
That's my job!
Yeah.
Try me.
Try getting me.
Checkpoints mean progress usually.
Yeah.
That's why I'm like...
Oh my god.
That's why I'm like... I think I want to go try the other way first.
Before we continue any further.
Over here.
What are you...
This is lazy.
Lazy bones right here.
The other path is a secret.
Okay.
Oh.
I missed a guy.
So he...
There must be a guy in the secret area.
I'm looking around.
I'm viewing everything.
We're so small.
Maybe I put water in it.
It's like a deer scare, right?
Here.
We'll do this one first then.
You jerk.
You.
That's why I usually kill those guys with my laser.
With this.
Otherwise, I don't trust it.
You know?
You!
There we go.
I'm not going to kill you.
Don't worry.
Not yet anyway.
You monster.
I am.
I'm the monster.
Oh my god.
I can't control my strength you guys.
I can't control my power.
Oh.
Everything's fine.
We're all good.
Let's wash this off.
Oh my god.
I got a puzzle piece for being kind.
This is why you should be cleanly everybody.
Good.
I lived.
But my gamers stink.
No.
There's monkeys looking at me.
There's got to be something over there, right?
Nope.
If I miss something, just holler.
Just go yodeling.
I hear someone.
The masks on them are awesome.
I know, right?
They're so cute.
Jump to the temple thingy.
But I don't know what that...
That thing over there?
I'll try.
I was afraid.
I want to make it.
But let me try.
Maybe I can make it if I'm big.
I knew I looked suspicious.
There we go.
What's around here anyway?
Oh, sorry.
Uh.
The chimney out.
Is the chimney going?
Oh.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Uh.
Ah, I see.
I see.
Okay.
Try again.
How can I get up the tree?
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
Ah, I see.
I see.
Okay.
Excuse me.
Oh, my God.
What the hell is that?
Oh, no.
This is the warp, though.
I have to redo the level.
Um.
A puzzle piece.
Hmm.
Oh.
Should I just grab it, though?
Oh, well.
Um.
I still have two guys and a puzzle piece.
I can go back.
Yeah.
I think.
I wish that's... that's the one thing about this game is they make you kind of go through it, you know.
Oh, hello?
Like when I go to the warp, I should be able to return to where I was, you know what I mean?
So I don't lose progress.
Oh my gosh.
Leave me alone!
That's right... oh, did I get you?
I missed a guy?
I missed one.
Dude, the far more coins... that's true, that's true, that's true.
It's only... it's a tiny... it's not a big complaint.
It's barely... I say complaint, it's not even like a complaint.
It's just like a... oh, it's an inconvenience, right?
But it's not like a... ugh, this is annoying.
What is a ghost's favorite Mario brother?
Oh, oh, this is timed!
Oh no, no, no, no!
Oh, there's a puzzle piece!
Okay, we got the other puzzle piece too.
Nice,
all right.
Okay, just because... okay, I said this before.
Uh, I'll say it again.
But uh, if I... please try not to backseat too much.
Because you know, just if I miss something...
Let me at least like explore first everything, okay?
So that I'm not just like...
So it's not just like... immediately.
Hey, you need to go do something.
Yeah.
Okay, there... oh, oh no wait!
I do need this one!
Because I need the... oh shoot.
I'm not gonna make it.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no, no, no!
No!
Timing.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Run!
Okay, I'll die.
I guess I'll die.
Yeah, it's like a really small window, right?
Oh no, I have to do this part again.
Okay, I got all three at least this time.
Is there anything down here?
Let's check.
Oh!
Ah!
That's a good thing I checked!
Oh my gosh!
Creepy Sightjacker!
Loses control at the sound of the siren.
Oh my gosh!
It's a good thing I checked!
See, it's stuff like that.
Like I know I said that like if I miss something, just let me know.
But let me have a chance.
Don't like tell me immediately.
Let me have a chance to look around a bit, you know?
Let me have a chance to look around a bit.
Oh!
It gets all of them at once!
Oh shoot!
Uh...
Shoot, shoot.
Oh my god!
The timing!
No!
Ah!
What the?
It literally like rejected me.
I got all of them at once though.
Oh please.
Where'd my coins go?
Oh!
I made it!
Yeah!
Um...
What's this?
Ooh!
That looks so soft.
Excuse me!
Can I help you?
Yeah!
I love being big and I love to destroy.
I love being big and I love to destroy!
Aaaa!
Secret!
Secret.
What if I... Does it stay that way though?
How long does it stay?
I see, I see.
Take that, take that, take that.
Nice.
Okay.
Secret.
Oh, oh.
There's like 10 of them there!
Oh wow, I got a really good aim with that one, huh?
Oh my goodness.
I just have to not stand here, you know?
Get sniped, nerd.
Yeah, I just have to...
Oh gosh, am I going to make this one?
Oh my gosh.
Ah, no!
I made it, I made it, I made it, I made it!
No!
Get washed, get washed, get washed, get washed, get washed, get washed, get washed, get washed, get washed, get washed, get washed, get washed!
Still want to get this guy though.
Oh, oh my god.
Wait, wait.
Oh, that was so close.
Hold on, I'll come for you in like two seconds.
Okay, hold on.
I need the coins!
Oh my god.
Pure-hearted puppet.
Prone to losing their head.
This is so... What's the game?
Who is that?
Maybe I don't know.
The hair looks like that guy.
From Puppeteer, a PS3 game.
I've never heard of it.
Looks like... Oh gosh, I can't remember the game name.
Whatever.
Yeah!
Destroy!
Destruction, destruction!
Okay, so we got... Let's see.
We have all the puzzle pieces, we know where the warp is, and we got all the people.
Should I just leave or...
That didn't do anything.
Okay.
I'm trying to... Should I go back to the warp?
I...
I don't know.
I can't decide.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I got him.
I did.
Oh, oh!
Nice, nice, nice.
It trickled down.
Because I know there's going to be the boss fight here.
Mmm...
Oh.
Never mind.
There's no boss fight.
This game, I swear.
How do you know when there's a boss fight and when there's not?
Never let Mint into a fine china shop.
It said... I don't know.
To keep you on your toes.
Men!
You know what?
I'm going to go back and get it.
I'm going to go back and get it!
We got this.
It wasn't that far in.
I think we can do it.
Speedrun.
Did they just floss in your face?
Yes.
They did.
And we can get more coins.
But I'm not going to get... Okay, we don't need you.
I'm not going to waste... Don't waste my coins!
Wait, where is the little sponge?
I get him down here?
Oh yeah, he's stuck in there.
That's right.
Speedrun.
Become sponge!
I forgot I had an outfit since I was a sponge the whole time.
Give me more money.
Oh, never mind.
Stingy.
Okay.
Oh, my money.
More money, more problems.
Destroy.
Destroy everything.
Gosh.
So satisfying.
You guys don't understand how satisfying it is.
It's so satisfying.
Get more money.
Oh, I can't get that big money yet.
Did I say this is my favorite power-up?
It's a good power-up to be a favorite one.
I'll just say that.
Okay, we're back.
It's right here.
Oh, I didn't mean to slide down so fast, but...
Speedrunning!
Oh, my God.
I was trying to run away.
On my depth perception.
That's okay.
Come here.
Sludgy man, die!
Okay.
All right.
Can we...
We can't...
Could we go up from this way, I wonder?
Maybe not.
Let's grab some money since I'm here.
Oh, no.
Never mind.
No.
You keep the money.
Oh, that's...
That's not...
All
right, guys.
We're here.
Okay.
Now I just have to make it.
I'll make it.
Hey, Arnold reference.
Stop understanding my references.
I was cooking.
I was like,
wait.
What if I...
What if I stop midair?
All right.
Flood that sucker's house.
Oh, there we go!
We got it.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
How do I defeat them?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
He's got to get tired.
I get it now.
Knock him while he's down.
Oh, never mind.
Shoot.
What the hell am I supposed to do with you guys?
No, please.
Spin attack.
Oh.
Oh, because he's a little screw.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay.
There we go.
God, that's bothering me.
Where are we going to go?
Clear.
Volcano world.
Furnace fever.
Secret.
See...
Oh.
Watch out.
Watch out!
Oh, no.
He's sick.
Oh, he's sick.
Lizard.
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, god.
Oh, Indiana Jones.
Oh, my goodness.
Wow.
Oh, cool.
They forced to survive before you even get the Checkpoint.
That's crazy.
Oh, Lava Turtles!
They're so cute!
They're like, you gotta be good.
You gotta get good to...
To even... What?!
I hit your ass!
Good thing I got the checkpoint.
Oh no, it's the...
Nice.
Oh, oh, oh!
I know how to defeat this guy now!
I got him!
Oh, okay.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
Oh, uh, pull him out!
Pull him out!
Okay, nice.
Once again, Astro Bot killing it with the music.
Oh, honey!
That's not how you kill him.
I don't even know if you can kill him.
Maybe not.
Okay.
Hot honey.
Puzzle piece behind?
Oh, I see it!
Thank you!
How do I get up there?
Like, so I suppose.
Yeah, I wish I was a sponge again.
I get so used to having the super powers, and the super powers are typically like, OP, that it makes me just be like, uh...
What a waste to not have it anymore.
You know?
Tire yourself out.
Okay.
Lava sponge.
Yeah, well, no.
Well, I mean, I guess...
I would have to be...
Uh, you know...
I have to have pools of water everywhere.
Oh my gosh.
Woo!
We're gaming.
We're gaming, everybody.
Can I kill this guy?
Nope.
You cannot kill them.
Okay.
I gotta stop trying!
I gotta stop trying to kill these guys.
I hear someone.
Oh, no!
Wait, who is that?
Uh...
Oh, this is so cool.
They look like candles.
Uh...
Oh, this is so cool.
See the button?
Yeah.
Uh...
Oh!
Oh,
wait.
I think I understand.
This is the way the platform moves.
Oh, I think I get it.
Maybe.
Get closer.
Oh!
Nice!
I got it!
Oh!
Yeah!
Okay.
I'm toasting.
Hey!
Leave him alone!
Who is this?
We missed one.
Neon Avenger lights up any room she's in.
We missed one!
Okay, wait.
Where?
Not the fan.
Where did we miss?
Is it that platform down there?
Oh!
See this skull?
I see!
Oh!
I see it!
I was so busy focused on the other guys.
Ah!
I don't think there's a way to get back over there, is there?
No!
Why does it have to be a one-way?
Oh, that's so rude.
Oh!
What is this?
Not
infinite!
Not infinite at all!
Wait.
Where do I go?
Oh!
Here.
What?
Seriously?
Nice.
I'll have to go back for that one guy.
I got you!
It's Electric Vigilante from Courier to Conduit.
Who?
Oh!
I have to jump for it.
Oh.
I can do it one more time.
There we go.
Let's see.
Ducky!
Oh!
But it's not unlimited.
Which way do I go?
Which...
How do I...
Okay.
Hold on.
What is that over...
What is going on over there?
Okay.
We're going to go over there first.
Thank you, Ducky.
Okay.
I had to plan my route.
What's going on here?
Okay.
We got the last guy.
Nice.
Oh!
I'm sauna-ing.
Very cute.
Oh.
I was going to say, and now I'm trapped.
But I'm not actually trapped.
Oh!
Come on!
But I have to go back over there.
Which is kind of nice.
Oh, gosh.
I don't have enough!
I gamed.
You guys, I gamed.
Gaming, gaming, gaming!
I...
Oh, it doesn't let you go back at all.
It says, nah.
If you miss it, you lose.
I missed him.
Too bad.
Loser.
Idiot.
Oh, they're flossing.
Yoope!
Let's go get that guy real quick.
Secret!
We can get him really fast.
He's kind of towards the beginning, so...
We can get it.
You left on the snake?
Yeah.
You think that he would be in the snake area, but...
Well, we only have one more world.
Oh gosh.
We have one more world still.
To go through.
And we'll see if he's in there.
We're not quite sure yet.
Secret.
Tire yourself out.
You know I probably don't have to get all the guys.
But it also makes things a bit easier.
To just kill them and get them out of the way.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
So it's over there.
It's over there.
Okay.
They dropped more coins too.
Exactly.
Okay.
Over there.
I see.
I'm not even going to pay attention to these guys.
Um...
3, 2, 1.
Okay.
Oh, I think I can just go.
Secret.
First try.
What's this?
Roguish conduit.
He's got the touch.
All these guys are from Infamous.
Never played that game before.
Can I just leave now?
Can I just leave the planet?
Nice.
I want to do gacha.
We'll do gacha after in the next world.
How much time do I have left?
I can keep going.
Secret.
Oh gosh.
This game is so fun.
One day I'm just going to like play...
Play Endurance.
This is so fun.
Okay.
Yeah.
You turn gold.
Trapped in time.
Aww.
Get that.
Get the money.
Yeah.
Whoa.
What was that?
Was that someone I need to get?
Wait.
It's nice because none of the levels feel...
Um...
Like...
Too long or anything.
Like I just feel like there are type of levels that I can just go on and play forever and ever.
Hey.
Come on.
I'm a chicken.
Chicken hat.
What's it do?
Okay.
Oh.
Can I only go up?
Why is all the music so good?
All the music just makes me feel...
Nostalgic for something.
Like...
Oh.
Is there anything else?
No.
I hate this guy.
Because he takes me...
I have to wait.
I want to just fight.
Wow.
I just want to fight.
I don't want to wait.
This guy.
These guys again.
Just double...
Oh.
Wait.
Let's see.
I knew it.
It does sound like Shantae.
Oh.
I hear it.
Wait.
Oh.
What?
What am I missing here?
Oh.
I just have the chicken again.
Just kidding.
Oh.
So far...
I think we're good.
I want to play more Shantae.
I hear you.
Where is the other guy?
Oh.
There he is.
Oh
my god.
I hear you.
Easy.
Sorry.
I just have to wait.
Is there anything else in here?
So hard to tell.
Nothing else.
Oh.
I thought maybe there might be something at the top.
You know.
Like all the way up there.
There could be.
What the hell are you?
Oh.
I got to grab your tail.
And...
Oh.
I think I did not do that correctly.
Wait for what does a new game.
Yars rising.
Oh, really?
What was that?
It didn't seem like water.
I don't know.
What's in here?
Oh.
Wait.
If I...
And then...
Oh, wait.
How do I use this thing again?
Oh shoot!
Oh my god!
I thought I was about to die!
What a drop, seriously!
Maybe it's the last... two...
In the end, I die.
In the end, I even die.
So what's the point?
It goes so fast!
Stop it!
Oh my god!
Give me your flower!
Okay, does he start going really fast?
Oh, so close!
There we go!
Holy cow!
It's over there!
Reggie, welcome to the membership!
Thank you!
Is this an actual game?
I thought this was just some sort of Playstation advertisement campaign.
Yeah, it's like the best game ever!
Hold on, I want to check over here.
I want to check over here.
To satisfy my own curiosity?
Okay.
Well, at least I got coins, okay?
Yeah, I guess you could say it's both, huh?
Oh.
I saw someone say boost inside here.
Which I think I tried before.
That didn't do anything.
Um... in here, maybe?
I see you down there!
How do I boost down?
Where's your tail?
Oh, now we can get him.
Never mind?
Wait!
No!
I thought we were going...
Thank you, Brick!
Glad you're having so much fun with this.
In case you missed it or forgot, the PS5 should come with Astro's Playroom pre-installed if you want a little more Astro sometimes.
Is there any chance we get a carry on stream this spooky season?
Maybe.
I've been keeping a list of games I want to do.
I think I might drop from here.
Wait!
No...
I've been keeping a list of games I want to do.
Uh...
So...
There's a ledge below.
There it is?
Over here, maybe?
Oh!
I see the...
It literally, like, shows you.
It's like, hey, by the way, there's, like, a ledge here.
And then even, like...
Oh, God.
There's someone by our side.
Oh!
Thank you!
Dream Chaser.
That's the right to bear.
Bear arms.
So I can't say definitively yes, but even if not for spooky season...
Um...
I like playing horror games all the time.
Where is the puzzle piece that I missed?
Don't
tell me.
Can I get a hint?
Anybody?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, that's just where they would pop out.
Golden.
Uh...
Was it this...
Was it when that snake was chasing...
Whatever that snake was chasing?
Inked.
Thanks, paper bag friend.
You're a real one.
You're a real friend.
Wait,
stop it.
Yes.
Oh, come on.
Stop!
So
left!
Oh!
I'm live!
That's so live.
Oh!
I hate the ones that are like that.
Oh, whoops!
I forgot to grab it.
Oh, there you go guys.
Oh, come on.
Don't be like that.
Ooo!
Oh my god, I lived.
That's right.
Actual Mario sand level.
Yippee!
Oh, I think I got a normie.
What?
So there's still... okay, so there's the one and then there's a bunch of guys, but there's the one other piece that we can get.
Oh!
Oh my god, I'm buried in riches!
I'm buried in... oh my gosh!
Can you guys even see me?
Can you guys see me?
You can see me there.
Oh my goodness.
So fun!
Sorry, I'm always constantly looking around just seeing if I got everything, you know?
Ouch!
Oh!
Oh, I got him.
I can stun him!
Oh, that's so good.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
Oh wait, I didn't stun him.
He got tired on his own.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Spidey bird!
Membership accurate!
Oh yeah.
Oh my god, he almost died in here.
We missed one.
Look, that could've been you.
That was almost him.
For real.
We missed one.
Up there?
I was so distracted by my riches.
I almost missed it.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind, but these are...
More riches!
Yippee!
Wait, I hear someone.
I thought I heard someone going...
Pause!
Oh my gosh, have you been waiting out this whole time?
I'm so sorry, girl.
One second, let me let my cat out.
My poor little girl!
I didn't hear her.
She knocked over so much stuff in my room.
I'm so sorry.
Not up here?
No?
She probably was hungry.
Oh, it's maybe these guys.
I think this...
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
Never mind.
Sorry, I'm a little blind.
Oh, that was close.
Nice.
Okay.
That's one.
Oh, okay.
I was thinking too hard about it.
I was like, I know I hear someone!
I think I need them to come back closer.
I know, I was too busy gaming.
I feel so bad.
I said blind.
I'm blind.
Yippee!
Bot rescued.
Okay, we got him.
Desert Wonderbird!
Great at making friends.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I thought I was about to die.
I thought there was like a little...
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Journey guy.
John Journey.
I'm Wilheimer Schmidt.
His name is my name too.
Scary.
Ah!
Oh!
Kamin!
To be fair, I was gaming.
To be fair!
Just let him die down there.
The gold mechanics.
Even I see all this.
Oh, shoot.
I see this and I'm like, whoa.
I've been ranting and raving about how beautiful this game is.
I have.
I'm not taking the graphics for granted.
I think it's really nice.
I think it's so, so nice.
Like I've just been like, whoa, I can push them all in there.
Such a good looking game.
It really is.
Let's see.
Okay, we got two guys left.
I can't believe I didn't.
I had to play like a...
I couldn't defeat the enemy.
I had to just leave.
I couldn't defeat him.
I just left.
I'm not a gamer.
I'm a loser.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Where did he come from?
Where did...
I was trying to go up here.
What?
Huh?
How did I do that?
I'm gaming?
I think I'm...
Maybe you guys...
Maybe I'm way more a gamer than I expected to be.
Oh my god, everybody say KFP.
So cute.
Yay!
Anything up here?
Don't touch the purple.
Nope, okay.
The purple looks really delicious though.
It looks like a taro ice cream, right?
Mmm...
So rude!
Oh, I got the...
What's it called already?
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Is it true that they think Americans eat KFC for...
As a Christmas feast?
I think that was like...
What they...
How they advertised it before.
To get people to eat KFC.
They were like, Yeah!
Americans eat it for Christmas!
He
just literally grazed him!
Are you kidding me right now?
Okay, I give up on that.
It doesn't even give me more money.
Maybe after a walk...
Maybe...
Ah!
It does give me more money!
Can you
grab it?
Wait, it's in the water!
I was gonna say it's in the death water!
Why is it giving me?
When I was young, my parents used to...
You just have to celebrate my birthday.
What, KFC?
Oh, KFC?
I can probably count the number of times...
I've had KFC...
On one finger.
We made it!
Oh, what is this?
I think we did it!
I missed a man.
No way.
Wait, I said one finger.
I meant one hand.
Hahaha.
The guy you missed is way back.
How is that even possible?
He's the last guy.
What do you mean, way back?
He's the literal last guy.
Oh...
Who the hell?
Gato!
You liar!
You trying to one guy me?
Huh?
You little bastard, huh?
They're way back.
You'll never get them.
Oh, yeah.
You totally missed your chance.
You're never gonna get that guy.
He's way too far.
What the hell?
Bang!
I swear
there was a guy on top of a bottle that you didn't grab.
I swear there was a guy on top of a bottle that you didn't grab.
I will try for the puzzle piece though.
Hold on.
Since it's right at the very beginning.
Let's keep trying for the puzzle piece.
Okay.
And we can get more coins.
Coins, coins, coins, coins, coins, coins, coins.
Wait.
I don't think I got it.
Coins, coins, coins, coins.
You passed 150.
Ah!
Let's go!
Boost!
Oh!
I got it!
First try.
First try, baby!
Alright, before we do the boss level.
Let's go home and do some gacha.
Let's do some gacha.
This would be like a spiritual successor to Little Big Planet.
I remember that was a big marketing game.
Maybe!
No!
I haven't encountered a single Little Big Man.
Yippee!
150 out of 300!
Whoa!
We got way more than I expected.
Is that the bathtub that everyone is telling me to go to?
I don't even have it open.
Jake, welcome to membership.
Gotcha.
Give me outfits.
No soda.
Resting place.
I give you concrete.
Thank you.
Cute!
What sucks about getting more guys is that it means...
Oh my goodness.
It means that there's more items inside.
Oh!
A paint!
Snow glow.
Oh, it's cute!
Oh my gosh!
It's so pretty!
Hi!
Happy!
Energy store.
This is coal, right?
You guys said?
It's so pretty.
Oh, this is a siren, isn't it?
Oh!
This is a siren, isn't it?
I have not finished siren.
So...
One day I'd like to.
Oh my god.
Scammed.
Scammed!
Luminous sign!
Oh, it's so pretty!
Hmm.
Oh!
An outfit.
An outfit, you guys.
Okay.
Oh!
I'm...
Mr. Bloodborne?
Happy!
Boy's bow.
Color?
Whoa!
Glorious graffiti.
A snake on there?
Fuji-san is on there.
But no snake is useless to me.
Whoa!
Worth its weight.
That is gold!
Happy!
Oh!
This is the puppeteer thing.
Oh, we got the tortoise!
Very cute.
Okay, one more.
So I want...
Oh my god, look how many outfits are in there now!
Please!
Let me have more outfits!
I want more outfits.
Let me check my Discord because...
there might be people...
trying to contact me...
for my sound check.
Oh!
I'm so bad.
I'm bad at game.
Okie dokie.
Let's keep going!
We have the one boss world.
Let's go!
Oh!
I should have changed into Mr. Bloodborne!
Oh well.
Oh!
Good, good, good.
Should have changed.
Also hidden world.
Yeah, but I don't think I'll be able to get...
them today.
That's okay though.
We'll see how fast this level takes me and then...
Oh wait!
Yeah, like these are...
Oh!
See, like here is hidden.
Right?
Oh!
Wow!
Lost circle void.
I'll try!
Let me see how long the boss takes me and then...
We'll see if we can do circle world.
Oh!
Oh gosh!
I did it!
More world.
Rolling...
Rolling Star Luna!
Anything else?
Hmm...
Since I unlocked it...
I won't have to unlock it again, right?
Okay.
Let's try.
Boss world!
Oh!
Crash landing!
This is like the first world we've had that has like spooky music.
I missed the world moving as an asteroid.
Yeah, I know.
And that's okay because...
It will come back.
Cool.
So it's no biggie.
Let's see... Oh!
Chicken!
Did I...
Did it lay an egg?
Wait, does my chicken lay eggs?
I know how to use chicken.
Oh, shoot.
Let me double check.
What's here?
Oh, just the one guy.
Okay, cool.
That makes things easy.
They usually do...
Yeah, but I didn't notice before!
He lays a little egg.
It's kind of cute.
Oh!
Ah!
Oh my god!
All my coins!
You jerk!
You made me miss all my coins!
No!
Okay.
Oh no, it's a snake lady.
Lady Venomara, please have mercy on me!
Oh my god, I'm over!
Wait, she's got about...
Oh my god, stop.
Don't be like that.
I can't die on the first part.
Start it!
Oh!
Okay.
We're learning her patterns, you guys.
We're learning her patterns.
Okay.
Oh!
I needed to jump on top of them!
Okay.
We understand now.
You can destroy the green knight?
Okay, I think yeah, I'll try.
I was so distracted by her chomping.
You know?
There we go.
Sow, nay!
I wasn't fast enough.
Okay.
Uh...
Am I supposed to...?
Wait, oh...
I
need to destroy her...
the things on her tails, right?
Oh wait!
Oh!
I got one!
Oh, I got two!
Nice.
Oh, come on.
Oh, they give you so many shots too.
And I just messed up.
It's me!
I messed up!
What just happened there?
Oh my goodness.
Oh, she's shaving off the field.
Oh, I kind of love her though.
Who's her seiyuu?
She's so awesome.
I
died.
I died.
Oh my gosh.
Ah, shoot!
I
keep missing the first one.
Oh, I got it!
I got it!
Nice.
Okay.
There's only so many places you can put these damn anxiety!
Oh my god.
Oh my
god.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
That was so close!
Oh my gosh.
Please don't let me fall.
Almost?
Oh my god.
Oh shoot!
No!
Shut up!
You can punch.
Yeah, I'm gonna punch instead.
Okay.
I know much better the patterns though.
So, it's good.
It's a good game.
B-boo pooh-pooh!
Oh my god.
Like
I got pretty far with just like a one life going on, so.
I raised it up.
Wasn't so bad, I suppose.
Oh, yo-yo-yo-y.
Concentrate.
I can't even talk, sorry guys.
I'm like concentrating so much.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Ah!
Locked in, I know.
Oh, just punch her blue stuff?
Oh, I thought you meant...
You meant the Eggies at the end!
Okay, okay, okay.
I get it, okay.
I thought you guys meant the Eggies before.
My bad.
Please, yes.
Oh, that was so close.
Sorry.
Okay, I'll try punching this time.
Punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch!
Punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch!
Punch, punch, punch, punch, punch!
There we go.
I got her.
Oh, okay.
There we go.
And so here I can just punch my way through, right?
Punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch, punch!
Oh, punch, punch, punch!
Oh, what?
Oh, never mind!
You cannot just punch!
You must...
Dodge!
You must dodge, I think!
Dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge!
Dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge!
Okay.
Woo!
Oh!
She's so hot.
Punch!
Yes!
Why...
Who's that?
What did he do?
Oh, it's Uncharted.
Close enough.
If evil, why hot?
So true.
Let's go!
Oh, sorry.
Yeah!
The boss!
Now we have the bossier boss.
And we have to beat the Uncharted world.
The bossier boss.
Dude raiding!
I kind of want to see this one, though.
I kind of want to see what the circle world is like.
Maybe I'll game just like before.
Oh.
Woo!
Thank you!
What does the circle world want for us?
Everybody.
It seems peaceful so far.
Seems quite nice, right?
So far, it's actually quite peaceful.
Oh, he looks like a SpaghettiO.
They really look like serial mascots, right?
Nanako Ishikawa.
Thank you for looking it up.
Okay.
Oh, boost!
Oh.
Rolling rampage.
Let's see.
SpaghettiO.
Oh.
What a second.
What's that?
I thought I was right!
Right?
Oh my god.
Oh, I already have one.
Oh, shoot!
What do I do here?
I don't remember!
Oh wait, what was I supposed to do with these guys?
My Oshijane's combat.
Oh, spin!
That's right!
Thank you.
I couldn't remember.
I'm too gaming.
I don't need to...
It's
a cord!
It's like a... it's like a...
It's like a... a controller cable.
It's so cute.
That's so cute.
Yeah!
PS1 cord.
Oh my god.
No, that's so unlucky.
Okay, alright.
Please!
No!
I don't have the timing down yet for it.
Maybe right as soon as... no...
No!
Okay, okay, okay, okay!
Okay.
Wait, this is bad.
Wait, this kind of sucks.
Wait, I can't see anything.
This is kind of... not so great.
No, they're so fast!
They're way faster than you!
Okay.
Okay, I understand.
I understand!
Oh!
I don't... I don't remember him being that bad.
Okay.
Wait!
Oh, it sucks because it's all the way on the other side.
So you have to like...
Ah!
Okay.
Run!
Jump!
Ah!
Okay.
Good luck, boss!
Do a flip!
Thank you!
I want ace combat!
I want strong ace combat!
Please!
Okay.
Alright.
I think this one's not so bad, though.
I think.
I think this one's quite doable.
As if the other challenges aren't doable.
Oh shit.
No!
That's okay.
Holy...
I...
I was gonna say I am farming coins but not really.
I lose it every time.
I lose the coin every time which sucks.
Okay...
But up to here, I'm okay.
Usually.
Please!
Yes!
Okay.
Save zone!
Okay, okay, okay.
You don't lose your coins?
But I've been at like 170 for... I checked earlier!
I haven't...
Okay.
No, no, no.
I was at 170 at the beginning of this.
Every time I die, I lose it.
Because at the beginning of this, I was at 170.
I'm not saying like I'm losing coins.
I'm saying like I will lose that mana.
Okay.
Alright.
Ah!
Aerial Ace!
A G-Force to be reckoned with!
Yes!
Charizard is coming!
Let's go, baby!
Oh my god, brother!
Get up!
Brother!
Oh, wait.
Where's... Oh, there it is.
Oh!
No, no, no!
Come back!
There's so many levels in this game.
Holy cow!
Try the top circle?
Okay.
Give me a second.
What is this?
Oh, gosh.
It's this guy.
Holy cow!
Oh, no.
No way!
Oh my god.
My coins!
Oh, let's see.
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness.
My coins!
Ah, shit!
No!
Your money or your life?
My money!
I don't know how I'm gonna get past those...
Oh my god.
This one's hard.
Oh, god.
I, like, circle around, not trying to get the coins.
I'm just trying to wait out his... I'm trying to wait him out.
Otherwise, I'm gonna get beat.
Oh, no!
You don't need to kill them?
I guess that's true.
Oh, you guys are so right.
Oh, yeah.
You're so right.
Okay, but what about the next guy?
What about that guy right up there?
What do I do about him?
Oops.
I was too... See, that's why I gotta wait around a little bit.
That's why I gotta wait around a little bit.
I
honestly don't know how I might...
Let's try the other one.
I'm already... I feel like I... That one's gonna get me tilted real fast, I think.
Like, that one's gonna get me tilted real fast.
Okay.
We'll see what all the other challenges are like and...
WE CAN DO IT!!
Bring it back!
What
am I...?
What the hell?
Ow, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Gimme, gimme, gimme, gimme, gimme, gimme.
Cool cut.
Okay, I gotta lock in, I gotta lock in, I gotta lock in, I gotta lock in, I gotta lock in, I gotta lock in, I gotta lock in.
No,
this is so unfair.
This is not fair!
What are you talking about?
Let me see him!
Please!
Just let me see him for two seconds!
Let me see him!
Please!
Oh no!
This is going to be my downfall for real!
Oh shoot!
He's going to keep shooting at me now, isn't he?
That's okay.
We can just kill him.
This is the motivation you need.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, please!
Oh, he's too evil, this guy!
He said, help me!
He said, Mito, help me!
That's what he said just now!
Oh my god, it was so sad.
He said, Mito, help me!
He did say, help me.
I might be...
making up the other part.
Jump towards the spikes when you have it.
Yeah, but they just produced so many.
I'm going to have to be so fast.
Okay.
Fast.
Speedy.
Speedy McGee.
He shot too fast.
Snake!
That's what he said.
Mito!
Oh my gosh.
Snake, I'm coming!
I'm coming, Snake.
I'm coming.
Oh my gosh, wait.
There's still more to the level.
There's still more to the level, Snake.
You gotta give me...
a second, Snake!
Okay.
What's happening?
What do I do with this?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, it's really heavy.
There's probably even going to be...
Okay, hold on.
I think I should drop it, right?
Uh...
And then pick up the rest?
And then...
You need it?
Okay.
Oh.
That's awkward.
Anyway.
Oh!
Did I...
Was I supposed to get another one or...
Oh, no.
Ha!
Yeah!
Snake, come here.
Come here.
Oh, my God!
Oh,
my God!
Legendary soldier.
Tip to become the big boss!
Okay, you're coming home.
Come on, Snake!
Get on the bus!
Get on the bus, Snake!
Snake, where are you?
Get on the bus.
Snake!
Going home.
I'm coming with you!
Shake him around a bit!
Oh good, you deserve it.
Thank you.
First try.
Snaaaake!
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, Snake next to Johnny's combat.
Come here you bitch!
You really gave me a fright!
Yeah you!
You!
Yeah!
Yeah you!
Really!
You really put me through it!
Snake!
That's not your home.
Who are those people?
What does he do?
He does nothing because we need gacha.
We need money.
Aww, I need money.
Wait, where is...
Where is Ace Combat?
I wonder if I can replenish your fluids.
I can hear you sweating and drooling.
Stop!
Oh, there he is!
Oh, he also needs...
We need more money.
Knock him off the cliff.
I can't wait to get a Pyramid Head sword.
How much money?
Oh, I can only do two guys.
Will we get lucky?
Ace Aircraft!
Oh my god!
Congrats, you got John Ace Combat play.
This machine!
Who even put soda in there?
Oh my god, he's playing with his little airplane.
It's so cute.
So cute.
Gosh, our little civilization is so good.
What does he
do when I hit him?
Nothing!
Stop being boring, Snake!
Snake, be fun!
Snake, don't be boring just because I'm poor!
That's so lame.
It's not fair!
What you need is gacha, I know.
Oh, he's making me feel poor.
Safari Park.
I
might end it here then.
Since I have rehearsal in about 30 minutes.
So I should probably get ready.
But we got Snake, you guys!
Oh, whoops.
We got Snake.
Is that it?
For Metal Gear characters?
Is there any more?
Don't say who.
I don't think there's anyone else.
There's one more!
And John Ace Combat.
Okay.
One more.
There's one more in the circle challenge?
I'm gonna go spoil it for me.
Okay.
I'm going to go split.
Spike, thanks for the 20!
There we go.
Let's go see who it is.
Hello Paisie!
Raiden!
Oh.
That's right.
I'm coming Raiden!
Oh shoot.
Don't just tease me like that!
What the hell is that?
Shoot.
I just got a notification on my phone that's like, um, rehearsal in 30 minutes.
Look at him!
Why does it got to be...
Why does it got to be Ryzen Raiden though?
Great first try.
Thank you.
Oh shoot.
We're locked in.
Oh shoot!
Ow!
It's actually not so bad up until this birdie part.
Why does it got to be...
Why do I have to...
Why does it got to be like that?
It's actually quite...
Not so bad.
Until...
Really this part.
Oh I can't see.
Okay.
Oh shoot!
Oh my god!
What the...
How am I supposed to...
How the hell am I supposed to avoid that?
You just got to speedrun it.
Okay.
Alright, last try.
Last try.
Oh my god.
I missed the rope!
Last...
Real last try.
I want to try on the birds.
That's...
That's where I...
Last try for real.
Get into the birds.
You know?
I shot.
Good.
Boom.
Crest
over!
You!
Yo!
Oh!
I think they should have put in Tony Hawk reference...
And multiple of them too.
Wait.
No no.
No no no!
No no no no no!
No!
Stop distracting me!
You're trying to sabotage me!
I know!
You sabotaged me!
I'll never forgive you!
You cursed me!
You sabotaged me!
Don't ask why.
Oh, I have to start on the left side?
I just do.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I can't even get to the rope!
I can't even get to the rope.
Okay, I give up.
For now.
Sorry Ryland, you're not as important as Big Boss.
You're not as important as Big Boss.
Okay.
Don't swing back and forth, just jump off of it again.
Gotta go on first swing?
Fine.
I'll try one more time.
Can't wait to see my Oshii on the Hornet tomorrow!
Yeah!
See you there John!
Thank you!
I'll see you there.
Okay, last try.
What comes after that part?
I
pressed over!
Oh my god.
That was spooky.
Okay.
First swing!
Okay,
now I give up.
Now for real.
Okay guys, thank you for streaming today.
I had fun.
I hope you guys had fun too.
We have just a couple more worlds for...
For...
The bots.
Like we have...
We have that big one down over here?
I don't think I'll like 100%, you know?
Like, if I don't complete all the challenges, that's okay.
Like, if I don't get all the challenge worlds, that's okay.
But of course I wanna at least like complete the main worlds in the story and stuff.
Huh?
I'm confused by your super chat.
But yeah, so then we'll have this one.
And then this one.
It really just depends on how I feel about some of the challenge places.
Maybe someday in the future I can do like a...
Just the challenges and endurance or something.
Great job getting snake!
Thank you!
Hope they have some wild arms characters.
Good luck with her.
So thank you!
Thanks Tri-Princess!
Thank you!
Thanks for the fun party!
Thanks for the fun stream!
You've definitely been getting better at this game.
Thank you!
Yeah!
Um...
Glad...
Today you got John Ace Combat.
We got snake and we got Ace Combat!
Oh, apparently they do Virlint!
You're so lucky!
But hopefully I can get them too.
But for now I'm gonna go!
And I will see you guys...
Tomorrow...
I'm gonna play...
Holocure?
I think I wrote on my schedule.
Can't remember what I wrote.
Um...
If you didn't see I posted like a mini schedule.
For the rest of the week on Twitter.
It's made in MS Paint so I wasn't gonna like...
I wasn't gonna like...
Post it anywhere else.
But next week we'll have a schedule for sure.
And tomorrow...
I have off-season Off-Kai concert.
So I'll be there as well.
And uh...
The weekend after I have another concert.
Um...
V-Muse.
In Malaysia.
Where I'll be also...
Performing together with KLP48!
One of the...
The official...
Sister group of...
AKB48!
So...
That's kinda crazy.
Two concerts...
In a row.
My...
My schedule for next week is kinda weird because...
I'm not sure exactly what time...
Things will be at for V-Muse.
So...
Uh...
Either Friday or Saturday I...
Won't be...
Um...
Streaming.
Not sure...
I don't know yet.
So...
Um...
I don't...
Wanna like...
Put my...
Put something out and then...
Have to take it back.
So...
Yeah!
But yeah!
Thank you guys!
Astro Bot is so much fun!
What does Scan do?
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
It's so frustrating!
I haven't compl...
I haven't...
I haven't 100%-ed literally any of these.
So frustrating!
Ah!
Maybe I'll try and get some of the puzzle pieces off stream.
I don't know!
You stop using BlueSky?
No!
I...
Um...
People told me a way to...
Be able to post...
Double post...
Cross post...
On Twitter and on BlueSky.
But...
Since I went to BlueSky...
I was in Japan.
I hadn't had time to set it up.
And...
Since I got back...
I hadn't had time to set it up.
So...
Um...
It really is just that.
And also...
I only have it on mobile.
I don't...
Can you...
Get on BlueSky on...
On...
Desktop?
I don't know.
Oh!
It is on desktop too?
Okay.
I have to remember...
My login.
I have to remember my login.
But once...
Once I have time to set up...
Everything...
I will.
My priorities have been focused elsewhere.
So...
Sorry...
If you use BlueSky...
And don't use Twitter.
And...
Um...
I haven't been posting there.
So yeah.
You mean a separate client?
No.
There is like...
Some...
People were telling me...
A way to cross post.
So that I can...
Post at both at the same time.
Cause...
I can't remember...
To post more than one place.
Can't wait to see you tomorrow.
See you tomorrow!
Yippee!
I can't bring my 5 foot JPEG dog.
So sad.
You could.
But I believe.
Okay!
Thank you guys.
Have a good night.
And I will see you...
Later!
Wait.
Before I leave.
One second.
Oh my god.
Look at him hanging out with them.
Keep running.
Keep going.
Faster.
Oh my god.
Get on my head.
And this...
I kind of look like Eva.
Don't I?
From behind.
I look like Eva.
A little bit.
It's the hair.
Not allowed.
He's too big.
No!
Wait.
She was blowing...
You guys didn't see that.
She takes the memory card out of her head.
And then blows into it.
She was blowing into her memory card!
Do it.
Do it again.
Show them all.
Spyro.
Get out of here.
Why do you think you're involved in this?
Do it again.
No!
Stop it!
It's not...
Snake, that's a big boss.
Yeah, I know.
Okay.
Well, she died from blowing into her memory card, apparently.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you...
Spyro, stop.
You're creeping me out over there.
Spyro.
Stop.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Snake.
They come here often.
I'm sorry.